من كم يوم اعلن رئيس هيئه الترفيه
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ عن مباراه غير شكل
ضمن الفعاليات موسم رياض واسمها كاس موسم
الرياض المباراه مقرره يوم 19 يناير ورح
تجمع نجوم فريقيا الهلال والنصر ضد نادي
باريس سان جيرمان
وستلعب على استاد الملك فهد الدولي يعني
بصراحه مباراه تاريخيه ونجوم تاريخيين راح
يشاركوا فيها رونالدو ميسي غير طبعا باقي
نجوم
والهلال والنصر طبيعي للاقبال على التذاكر
راح يكون كثير عليه لكن اللي صار كان
بصراحه مش طبيعي فطلبات التذاكر تجاوزت
مليونين وطبعا التذاكر خلصت المستشار تركي
ال الشيخ ومع المباراه تاريخيه تذكره
تاريخيه كمان اسمها فوق الخيال مثل شعار
موسم رياض السنه بالضبط وهاي مميزات
التذكره
اهلا بالعالم هذه فرصتكم للمزايده العمر
الحدث الكروي الاكبر المرتقب مباراه اكبر
الفرق فريقي فقيسا جيرمان ونجوم الهلال
والنصر في يوم 19 يناير للشخص المحظوظ
تذكره فوق الخيال ميزاتها حضور تتويج
مباراه النجوم بجانب معالي المستشار تركي
ال الشيخ فرصه مقابله كريستيانو رونالدو
ميسي
حضور حفل الغذاء فقال لهم ودخول غرفه
ملابس الفريقين الفائز بالتذكره سيشارك في
حفله تتويج ويكون في الصوره الجماعيه مع
الفريق الفائز يبدا المزاد بمليون ريال
سعودي وبامكانكم المزايده على المبلغ في
حساب معالي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ في
تويتر وجميع دخل هذا المزاد يذهب الى منصه
احسان الخيريه المسؤوله عن جميع الاعمال
الخيريه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه يغلق
المزاد الساعه 10:00 من يناير الساعه
11:30 مساءا مقعدك ينتظرك لا توسع
[موسيقى]
والمزاد مشاهدينا بدا من مليون ريال
وبدانا بعدها نسمع الارقام اثنين مليون
اثنين ونص مليون اربعه مليون سبعه مليون
وبعدين تسعه مليون والان السعر زي ما ذكرت
صارت تسعه مليون ريال و300,000
مثل ما شفت مشاهدينا كمان راح تشوفوا
امامكم الان شركه زوم قدمت عرض لشراء
تذكره ب 9 مليون و300 الف ريال كل هذا
ولسه على فكره زي ما سمعته قبل قليل باقي
على المزاد لسا سته ايام راح متابع طبعا
مع بعض ونشوف راح توصل او يوصل هذا الرقم
لوين